Israel probably has more criticism per
square foot square person than any
country in the world it's a democracy
they criticize they can be criticized
nobody's immune from criticism and no
you don't become an anti-semite
just because you criticize the Jewish
state but and there was an Sharansky one
of the prisoners of conscience from the
Soviet Union who set a certain standard
which I think sort of applies and he
said well if you criticism denigrates or
demeans israel or its existing or it
challenges its right to exist
that's not criticism because people
don't go around asking whether poland
should exist or china should exist so if
the question is the criticism goes to
the point of Israel's legitimacy
that's not criticism that's that's at
this point anti-semitism if it goes to
if it sets a double standard and
basically you know there's this issue
Dowler boycotts
I've seen boycotts student boycotts
church boycotts of Israel and the reason
is we are for human rights and we want
to show the world that we and I'd say
fine if you want to use boycotts to
express yourself to strengthen human
rights fine but if this wheel is the
only country that you select to use the
boycott enforce Human Rights and you
ignore China and Cuba and Sudan and
Saudi Arabia where there are violations
galore of human rights women's rights
gay rights religious rights etc that's
not legitimate criticism of Israel
that's that's bigotry that's
anti-semitism now if you make a list of
ten fifteen countries and you clued
Israel I will argue that Israel has
equal rights for women has respect as a
judicial system Palestinians can come to
the courts all that but okay you know
that's I can I can live with that but
when the only country when you look at
the United Nations you know okay do you
want to criticize this real find
but what
40% of the agenda of the United Nations
Human Rights so-called Human Rights
Council is only Israel
that's anti-semitism